Claire I'll start with you Elizabeth
Salander is such an iconic character so
when you decide to play her you go back
and look at what Noomi Rapace and Rudy
merited or do you just go and clean
absolutely do not go look at what they
did because I would have sleepless
nights I'd already watched what they did
as a fan and think they're amazing and
when you see a film like that and you
see work like that it stays with you
don't forget it so there were there were
definitely days and moments where I was
like they wouldn't be doing this what am
i doing but no I genuinely I went back
to the books really I just read the
books and and then that would they were
my my main source really you know it's
such a dynamic character did you push
yourselves in ways as an actress that
maybe you'd never pushed yourself before
I'd be curious yeah and I think weirdly
I sort of thought that it would be one
of those ones where I pushed myself in a
way I was like really free and kind of
like not being really like expressive
but actually I'm more push myself in a
in the sense that I just decided not to
overthink everything and I just went
with what your fairy suggested something
I'd be like okay sure
I'm not going to think about I'm talking
to him and that was very new for me I
just didn't want that burden of kind of
trying to get it right so I just went
for my instincts really and sometimes it
works and sometimes it is
are you not this with selecta the
righter of wrongs
the girl who hurts mention who had me
tell me about this film what did you
want to bring to this movie that maybe
we didn't see in the previous versions
of Lizabeth story well I don't think for
any of us we don't make the movie by
contrast we don't look at the deal
wanted to go like they'd done that let's
do something different we just we just
make the best movie we can and we had a
script that I wrote with a bass from the
co-writer we real believe in it and we
try to execute that as best and
naturally because it's my movie and I'm
the director it just becomes it becomes
something that is kind of attached to my
body of working away and in a kind of
strange way so but this one had room for
that I mean not a lot of this movies
they have room to fluff your maker to
make it their own when I watch your
movies I think intensity and not
expected this I'm always on the edge of
my seat yeah when I watch his movie that
he has that I think so yeah that's there
definitely an intention it's obviously
the world of the millennium and is the
word of Dragon to chew but it does have
I mean obviously those are the world
that go well with those objectives
you